[Musique]
nos équipes doit
et aussi
vaccinodromes - vaccinodromes à paris
qui nous permettrait d'accroître nos
capacités
ça me paraît évidemment très important
d'anticiper vacciner donc ouvrir à tous
les vaccins accompagné c'est à dire
arrêtez ce tu le ce de ce désordre le
chaos insupportable qui a dans
l'éducation nationale où monsieur blanc
caire est certainement je suis dangereux
claque au vide à force avec syndrom qui
a ouvert vous le savez au stade de
france qui me semble pas très éloigné de
paris quand même même si parfois pour
certains on a l'impression que ce qui se
passe au delà du périphérique relève
d'un no man's langues mais voilà des
gens arriver certains en pleurs car ils
découvraient que c'est et astrazeneca et
qui n'en voulait pas alors vous pouvez
me dire en chantant dans tous les
plateaux de télévision oui les risques
c'est vrai qu'ils sont ultra minimes
m'attendais aujourd'hui la publicité
fait tout ce qu'il ya eu autour
d'astrazeneca vacciner vacciner et
spatiales je vais rentrer vous savez
dans le show est de ceux qui vont
vacciner
oui c'est une ville déjà le 18 mars je
me ferai vacciner je l'astra zen est
carré bien je le ferai oui je vais le
faire dans les tout prochains jours
alors il faudra certainement qu'ils
reçoivent une seconde dose de vaccin
pour être protégé pleinement contre le
risque de covin ça pourrait être un
autre vaccin si je vous suis bien c'est
une éventualité qui est qui est
considéré de vous aurez la science et la
limite d'âge selon les pays c'est un peu
au doigt mouillé regarder cette carte de
l'europe des recommandations astrazeneca
la france a placé la barre à 55 ans la
belgique aussi mais ses 60 ans en
allemagne en italie ou en espagne et
depuis hier en un petit nouveau avec une
idée très originale
la grande bretagne a tranché astrazeneca
ce sera seulement pour les plus de 30
ans quand on m'a montré des images j'ai
reconnu la personne d'accord je ne peux
pas vous dire autre chose que c'est une
personne qui a les cheveux gris
ok ok on n'a pas quarante mille des
hommes politiques qui ont des charges
quand même a quand même
le gouvernement je pense pas d'accord le
président de la république a rappelé à
la fois sa confiance et son exigence
vis-à-vis des membres du gouvernement
évidemment aucune complaisance il a
rappelé évidemment aussi son attachement
à ne pas rentrer dans une société de la
délation et de la calomnie permanente
franck riester ministre en charge du
commerce extérieur s'est défendu d'avoir
participé à de telles soirées we dans un
tweet
on va le découvrir ensemble d'ailleurs
ce tweet je vois mon nom associé ici et
là la polémique qui entoure la tenue de
dîners kandestin il dit que ces rumeurs
sont totalement fausses et choquant
alors l'équipe
la team macron a trouvé une parade ce
matin j'ai tu as mangé les
fonctionnaires au pays en disant nous
allons supprimer des narces pourquoi ça
veut dire maintenant mais je reviens
pour ça comme ça va pouvoir jeter des
pierres aux hauts fonctionnaires à
l'état bon tout ça c'est de la
politicaille comme il l'avait promis
après la crise des gilets jaunes
emmanuel macron annoncé une réforme de
l'ena la prestigieuse école nationale
d'administration sera remplacé par un
institut du service public c'est toute
la haute fonction publique un qui
devrait connaître un lifting trop tweet
alors est ce sur un ton plus
humoristique celui de michel polnareff
je n'ai pas organisé en fouillant dans
les archives on est retombé sur deux
trois têtes connues pendant leurs études
à l'ena
michel colin accuse expert comptable est
lui encore fils de professeur
d'université
martine aubry fille des hauts
fonctionnaires martine aubry en 74 mais
aussi ce jeune homme qui avait 26 ans en
1996 pour vous c'est donc un bon choix
pour moi je suis ton excellent fois j'en
suis très fier deux fauteuils seulement
pour trois officiels la présidente
ursula von der leyen contraints de
s'installer en retrait sur un canapé une
scène désormais baptisé
sauf fagiht on est tombé sur la rebelle
celle qui organisaient un sit in à paris
parce qu'elle refusait que l'ena des
ménages à strasbourg et tout ce que vous
direz sourds oui oui je vous souhaite de
revenir